pues nos quedamos en el problema número
10 así que voy a trabajar con él y el
problema número 10 me dice lo siguiente
si 2 x menos 2 esto a su vez
x 2 menos x
esto es igual a 0 lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale x y bueno esta es una
pregunta que me gusta mucho porque tengo
dos números multiplicándose este por una
parte y después este por otra parte dos
números multiplicándose que su
multiplicación me da cero y si yo tengo
dos números que se multiplican que su
multiplicación me da cero forzosamente o
el primero es cero o el segundo cero
pienso un poco en ello eso es muy
importante o este cero o este otro es
cero no queda de otra
si tengo dos números que se multiplican
uno tiene sus tienen que ser cero para
que el resultado me de 0 3 por 0 0 10
por 13 0 por lo tanto estoy diciendo que
aquí 2
x2 esto tiene que ser igual a cero o
este cero o en su dado caso el otro es
cero o este dakar
2 - x esto es igual a cero no queda de
otra o la primera expresión es cero o la
segunda es cero ahora si pensamos que la
primera expresión es cero pues de aquí
puedo despejar la x de una manera muy
sencilla
2x es igual a 2 pase este 2 del otro
lado consignó contrario o sume dos de
ambos lados de esta ecuación y por
último me quedaría que x es igual a 2
entre dos lo cual es uno si dividido
entre dos ambos lados de esta ecuación y
aquí está tengo una equis para la cual
esta expresión se hace cero ahora
también tengo la posibilidad de que 2 -
x sea cero si 2 - x es 0 pues también
está muy sencillo resolver esta ecuación
yo puedo pasar esta x del otro lado y
entonces me va a quedar que 2 es igual a
x o de otra manera x es igual a 2 y aquí
es también resolución cuando x vale 2
entonces esta expresión también se hace
0 y de u2 lo puedes comprobar de una
manera y analíticas y equipo no es el 12
por 12 menos 1200 por lo que sea me va a
dar 0 y si yo aquí pongo el valor de 2
en x me va a quedar 2 - 2 que 0 y 0 por
lo que sea es 0 entonces aquí tengo mis
dos respuestas o x1 y x2
ok y entonces ya tengo mi solución
la clave de este problema es recordar
que si tengo la multiplicación de dos
expresiones o de dos números cuya
multiplicación es cero o el primero cero
o el segundo es ser muy bien así que
borremos este pizarrón y vamos a hacer
el siguiente problema el problema número
11 el problema número 11 que me dice lo
siguiente si x cúbica es lo mismo que he
elevado a la potencia número 9
cuánto vale x en términos de y wow pues
no está tan difícil este problema si
recuerdas las leyes de los exponentes
por qué porque si yo quisiera saber el
valor de x el valor de x en términos de
james entonces lo que necesito es saber
el valor de x elevado a la primera
potencia recuerda que x es la primera
potencia es exactamente lo mismo y para
eso se me ocurre poner aquí x elevado al
cubo de esto voy a partir y por acá voy
a poner allí a la novena potencia ahora
si nosotros recordamos que lo que yo
haga de un lado lo tengo que hacer del
otro entonces qué te parece si de este
lado de la igualdad a esta expresión la
elevó por un tercio y bueno también de
este lado voy a tener que elevar a la un
tercio pero lo que quiero que entiendas
es la profundidad o la importancia de
elevar este lado a la un tercio porque
si recuerdas las leyes los exponentes
cuando yo tengo una variable elevado a
una potencia y eso a su vez elevado a la
otra potencia entonces las potencias se
pasan multiplicando en este caso vamos a
obtener x elevado al cubo elevado a la
un tercio es exactamente lo mismo que x
elevado a la 3 por un tercio y 3 por un
tercio es lo mismo que 1 que es justo lo
que yo quiero
de esta xv hoy y bueno si esto es lo que
hago de un lado de esta ecuación esto es
lo mismo que voy a hacer del otro lado
de la ecuación a esta parte de la v
eleva también a la un techo ok y que me
va a quedar
bueno pues acabamos de recordar que las
potencias se pasan multiplicando
entonces aquí me va a quedar x elevado a
la 3 por un tercio y 3 por un tercio es
1 por lo tanto me queda x elevado a la 1
pero pues sé que es elevado a la uno
mismo que x mientras que del otro lado
me va a quedar bien elevado a la 9
elevado al un tercio y cuantos 9 por un
tercio 9 por un tercio bueno pues esto
es lo mismo que nueve tercios y esto es
lo mismo que tres bordo tanto x es igual
a jane elevado a la 3 y es justo lo que
quería el valor de x en términos de
james es y elevado al cubo si partimos
de esta expresión que por cierto este es
el inciso c lo único que hice fue
multiplicar 9 por un tercio
bueno pues el problema 11 sencillo
vayamos al problema número 12 que tiene
una gráfica entonces déjame hacer la
gráfica con el siguiente color voy a
tomar este color y vamos a hacer un
plano cartesiano por aquí está el margen
de las x medio de las 10 perdón ok por
acá tengo mi eje x muy bien vamos a
poner que este es el eje x este de aquí
es el eje i y tengo un triángulo pero
antes vamos a poner un poco de escalas
aquí tengo uno aquí tengo dos aquí tengo
tres por acá también tengo el 1 el 2 y
el 3 y por acá tengo el menos uno aquí
tengo al menos dos aquí tengo el menos
tres y tengo un montón de rectas que
hacen como una especie de trébol tengo
dos triángulos por aquí el primer
triángulo parte de aquí sube
el punto más o menos como por acá y
después de kim baja baja de aquí hasta
un punto más o menos como por acá y
después se cierre para acá ok tengo este
triángulo de aquí y por otra parte tengo
otro muy parecido a éste un triángulo
que se va para cam aunque algo más o
menos así después se va para acá
ok llega a un punto como por acá y
después sube hasta este punto ok y lo
que me preguntan es lo siguiente en los
segmentos de rectas siguientes cuando
las siguientes rectas tienen una
pendiente de menos 12 saber es cuál de
estas rectas tiene una pendiente o no
déjame cambiar de herramientas cuál de
éstos tiene una pendiente de menos 1
ok y para esto recuerda que la pendiente
es lo que cambiamos en jake con respecto
a lo que cambiamos en x una pendiente de
menos 1 nos estamos refiriendo a caminar
uno hacia la derecha la comparación de
caminar uno hacia abajo una pendiente de
menos uno es precisamente esto por cada
uno que camina la derecha voy a caminar
uno hacia abajo y bueno es una pendiente
negativa por lo tanto es muy recta
tendría que decrecer entonces si
recordamos un poco todo lo que tienen
que ver con pendientes de una manera
rápida me podrás decir que todas las
rectas que crecen de aquí no van a tener
pendiente negativa ni siquiera pendiente
-1 por lo tanto ésta no va a ser mi
respuesta esta también crece por lo
tanto no va a hacer mi respuesta y ésta
también crece por lo tanto no va a ser
mi respuesta solamente me queda esta
esta y ésta ok pero ahora vamos a
analizarlas con calma fíjate bien qué
pasa con esta recta empieza aquí y baja
hasta acá lo que quiere decir que nos
movimos una unidad en equis y bajamos
tres unidades en james por lo tanto esta
recta tiene una pendiente negativa pero
además de tener una pendiente negativa
tiene una pendiente menor a menos 1 de
hecho esta recta de aquí tiene una
pendiente de menos 3 tiene una pendiente
de menos 3 porque por cada tres unidades
que bajamos en james caminamos una a la
derecha en x por lo tanto ésta tampoco
es mi solución vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa con esta otra recta esta recta
empezamos aquí y caminamos 3 en x hasta
llegar hasta acá caminamos 3 s la
derecha y cuando caminaba ustedes es la
derecha bajamos solamente 1 por lo tanto
podemos decir que esta recta de aquí
tiene una pendiente de menos un tercio
es decir que por cada tres que nosotros
caminamos hacia la derecha este tres de
aquí nosotros vamos a bajar uno
y uno de aquí y bueno la pendiente de
menos un tercio no está pendiente de
menos uno de hecho nosotros podemos
pensar que cualquier recta que tenga
pendiente de menos uno se va a ver más o
menos así déjame dibujarte una se va a
ver más o menos así porque porque
recuerda que tenemos una pendiente que
nos dice que por cada unidad que
nosotros nos formamos hacia la derecha
nos vamos a mover la misma cantidad
hacia abajo hacia la derecha hacia abajo
es más déjame ponerlo así que por cada
cantidad que yo me mueva hacia la
derecha la misma cantidad me tengo que
mover hacia abajo por cada cantidad que
yo me mueva a la derecha la misma
cantidad debe caminar hacia abajo o que
hay y si te das cuenta ésta se parece
muchísimo esta no es déjame de charlar
esto tampoco es déjame de charlar esta
tiene una pendiente de menos 3 ésta
tiene una pendiente de menos un tercio y
vamos a revisar esta creo que esta
parece ser una buena opción porque
recuerda que la pendiente es lo mismo
que el alce entre el avance entonces qué
punto tenemos aquí bueno tenemos el
punto 1 en x 1 en x y 3 3 en 10 ok y
este punto que tenemos aquí bueno pues
este es el punto 3 en x 3 en x y 1 en 3
1 ok y si nosotros calculamos la
pendiente entre estos dos puntos la
pendiente va a ser igual a la diferencia
en yemen a comparación de la diferencia
en x que en este caso que en eso la
diferencia en 10 es 3 - 13 menos 13
menos 1 ya esto lo voy a dividir en tres
la diferencia en x la diferencia en x es
uno menos 31 menos 31 menos 3 y cuando
es esto 3 - 1 es 2 y después uno menos 3
- 2 lo cual me da una pendiente de menos
1 perfecto que era justo lo que quería
esta es la recta que yo estoy buscando
aunque ten cuidado también nosotros
podemos tomar la pendiente utilizando
primero este dato es decir me quedaría
que esto es lo mismo que uno menos 3 la
diferencia en 1 - 3 ya estoy dividido
entre 3 - 1
pero el resultado de esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo - 2 entre 2 lo cual
es menos 1 así que ya está la recta que
tiene como pendiente menos 1 es esta de
aquí y también lo podemos averiguar
porque date cuenta que por cada
distancia que nosotros recorremos hacia
la derecha la misma distancia vamos a
recorrer hacia abajo tengo una pendiente
de menos 1 de menos 1 que es lo que yo
quería así que de lujo nos quedó este
problema me gustó bastante pues es hora
de pasar al problema número 13 antes de
que se nos acabe el tiempo así que vamos
a hacer un último problema el problema
número 13 que dice lo siguiente la
combinación del candado de carlos está
compuesta por tres números de dos
dígitos wow eso suena a un número muy
grande
la combinación satisface las siguientes
tres condiciones vamos a apuntar las la
primera condición que me dice uno de los
números es impar primera condición
de los números es impar
uno de los números y solo uno de ellos
tiene que ser impar impar perfecto ok el
número 2 me dice uno de los números es
múltiplo de 5
uno de dos números
uno
de los números es múltiplo de 5
un blog
de 5 perfecto y el número 3 me dice lo
siguiente uno de los números es el
número del día del mes en el que carlos
cumple años ok el número 3 condición
número 3 me dice que uno de estos
números
de los números es el día en el que
carlos cumpleaños es el cumpleaños de
carlos
cumpleaños
d
carlos y por cierto es el día del
cumpleaños de carlos el día solamente el
día por lo tanto uno de estos números y
esto es lo que me está diciendo uno de
estos números tiene que estar entre el 1
entre el 1 y el 31 ok ya que tenemos
aquí las tres condiciones dice si cada
número cumple sólo una de las
condiciones escritas arriba es decir que
cada uno de los tres números de dos
dígitos que te voy a dar cumple
solamente una de estas condiciones ok
cuando las siguientes ternas de números
puede ser la combinación del candado
perfecto
ok pues vamos a fijarnos las opciones
inciso a el inciso a me dice 14
14 20 y 3 14 20 y 13 o keith pues
pensemos en la condición número 11 de
estos números tienen que ser impar el 13
es impar por lo tanto este me sirve el
13 es
así que va a cumplir la condición número
1 vamos a ver si cumple todas ok el
número 2 dice uno de estos números de
dos que sobran debe de ser múltiplo de 5
10 20 es múltiplo de 5 así que creo que
vamos bien uno de estos números debe de
ser múltiplo de 5 así que este cumple
esta condición y date cuenta que estamos
eligiendo para cada uno de estos números
solamente una condición y el número 3
dice uno de estos números es el día del
cumpleaños de carlos bueno pues carlos
puede cumplir años un día 14
nadie limita a carlos a que no cumpla un
día 14 puede cumplir un día 14 porque 14
está entre 1 y 31 por lo tanto este paga
esta restricción y ya está mi respuesta
es el inciso am y de hecho ahora que
hemos estado haciendo varios vídeos del
st me he dado cuenta que algunas de
estas preguntas sobre todas las
preguntas en las que es necesario
fijarse uno a uno los incisos de las
respuestas casi siempre cumplían que la
solución está en los primeros incisos
el e7 es un examen contra el reloj lo
que te piden es que no pierdas mucho
tiempo por lo tanto cuando tengas una
pregunta en donde tienes que verificar
uno a uno los incisos casi siempre la
respuesta va a estar en los primeros
incisos así que ataca el problema desde
el primer inciso hasta el último por
ejemplo en este caso la respuesta fue el
inciso am y de hecho sería muy bueno ver
que los otros sencillos no funcionan al
menos uno más ya no tengo tanto tiempo
pero vamos a ver por qué no funciona el
inciso b el cis orbe es 14
25 y 13 14 25 y 13 qué raro parece que
sí cumple
uno de estos números debe de ser impar
es este uno de estos números debe de ser
múltiplo de cinco es este y uno de los
números puede ser de los de carlos casos
puede cumplir el día 14
porque no funciona y ya no tengo tiempo
así que me empiezo a sentir un poco
presionado ya está ya ya ya uno de los
números del múltiplo de 525 uno de los
números debe ser impar y además recuerda
que solamente uno de ellos podría ser
impar así que aquí es donde pierde el
inciso b porque tengo dos números
impares tanto éste como este y solamente
me pedían que uno de ellos fuera impar y
aquí tengo dos impares es por eso que no
funciona el inciso b y así con todos los
demás incisos cuando tengas un problema
de este estilo no olvides verificar
siempre los primeros incisos seguramente
ahí encontrarás la respuesta